major events for new year's eve they've
been canceled as you know because of the
pandemic
overnight the lvcva did announce some
plans though to ring in the new year
here in las vegas our bianca holtman
joins us live in the newsroom with those
details hi viaga
new year's eve celebrations will look a
lot different this year with folks
ringing in 2021
from their couch many of our city's
traditions will be on hold
vegas will still own the title of
america's party with the phrase
out with the old in with the new on
december 31st you can log on to the web
for an only vegas celebration this
virtual event isn't just for us locals
visitors who come to the strip on new
year's eve
can watch from anywhere we will be
live streaming a about a 12 to
15 minute program including a
uh explosion that allows us to close the
door on 2020
but also ring in the new year with
fireworks virtual fireworks so
globally our fans and visitors can tune
in
from around the world and join us
in this celebration so it's it's our way
of keeping vegas top of mind now those
who tune in will enjoy a dj and they can
share
what they are most looking forward to in
the new year for a chance to win trips
in 2021
and you and your friends can raise a
glass to of course celebrating
safely you can watch the stream on visit
las vegas website
their facebook page or youtube channel
reporting bianca holman
8 news now all right thank you bianca